اوقاتكم اذا مشاهدينا نواصل معكم اليوم
هذه التغطيه الحيه والمباشره على شاشه
العربيه التغطيه المستمره منذ الصباح
والتي تحدثنا وتابعنا فيها لحظه بلحظه
الهزه الارضيه التي ضربت تركيا وشمال
سوريا والتي بلغت قوتها
7.8 درجات بمقياس ريختر حول اخر الاحصاءات
حول ضحايا الهزه المدمره اعلنت سلطات
التركيه عن مقتل 1014 شخصا فيما بلغ عدد
القتلى في شمال سوريا 812 قتيلا وهي ارقام
مرشحه للزياده بعد رفع الانقاض
اذا الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا صباح
اليوم كان ثاني اقوى زلزال يضرب البلاد
منذ زلزال
1939 حيث شعر بالهزه الارضيه عدد من الدول
المجاوره فيما كان مركز الزلزال كهرمان
مرعش الواقعه شمال مدينه غازي عنتاب في
منطقه تبعد تسعين كيلو مترا عن الحدود مع
سوريا
وكما ذكرنا فان زلزال الذي ضرب اجزاء من
تركيا صباح اليوم كان اكبر زلزال تشهده
تركيا منذ قرن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اشار في كلمه له الى ان زلزال
الاخير يعد اكبر كارثه تشاد البلاد منذ
عام
1939 معلنا عن ارتفاع عدد ضحايا في البلاد
الى 14 قتيلا وخمسه الاف وثلاثمائه وخمسه
وثمانين مصابا فضلا عن اعداد كبيره من
المفقودين اردوغان اكد كذلك ان القوات
المسلحه تباشر اعمال الانقاذ في المناطق
المتضرره وان 45 دوله عرضت المساعده بعد
الدمار الكبير في نحو 11 ولايه وكانت قلعه
غازي عنتاب التاريخيه تعرضت لانهيارات
كبيره خلال زلزال
اردوغان وفيما يتعلق بالمساعدات تاكد ان
45 دوله الى جانب نيتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
تشارك في اعمال الانقاذ لمواجهه اثار
الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
يقيني هل تسبب في هدم واضرار في عدد من
المحافظات وسبب دمارا كبيرا المحافظات
استنفرت كل قوتها الى جانب المحافظات
ادارات الولايات لهذه المحافظات ومؤسساتنا
التي تعنى بالكوارث القوات المسلحه
التركيه ايضا تم توظيفها في تلك المناطق
اولويتنا كانت ولا زالت هي اعمال الانقاذ
حاليا يوجد 9000 عنصر ضمن فرق الانقاذ
وسيتزايد هذا العدد
وننتقل
واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام الان الى تصريحات
الوزير العدل التركي نشاهد الان مباشره
نستمع
اذا بانتظار
ما تعمل على الاملاحقه اصحاب هذه الاخبار
الكاذبه التي تنتشر
نحن نقوم
بتقديم كل المعلومات والمستجدات
ضروريه الاستماع الى هذه
الاخبار التي تصدر والاعلانات التي تظهر
سنعود مره اخرى لنتابع في الشان التركي
وفيما يتعلق بالمساعدات اكد اردوغان ان 45
دوله الى جانب النيتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
تشارك فعلا في اعمال الانقاذ لمواجهه اثار
الزلزال في تركيا
بني سنبله حاليا هناك 912 مواطن توفي وما
زاد على خمسه الاف جريح
2,800 مبنى وهدمت بالكامل العديد من
المباني تضررت لا زالت عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره لا ندري الى اي مدى ستصل هذه
الارقام وبشان المساعدات الدوليه نتواصل
مع الدول الاخرى الى جانب الناتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي هناك 45 دوله قدمت طلبا لتساعدات
هذه الكارثه
نعود مره اخرى
لمتابعه تصريحات وزير العدل التركي والتي
تتعلق بالاحداث التي
تابعناها اليوم في تركيا والزلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا نتابع الاولى من الصباح الان هم
في حاله جيده طبعا التنسيق مع مبنى
الولايه وايضا البلديات والهلال الاحمر
وافاد هناك تنسيق كامل مع كل المؤسسات
الرسميه وغير الرسميه ايضا من اجل انقاذ
المواطنين من تحت الانقاذ الاعمال
المستمره كما ذكرت قبل قليل علينا ان
نتقدم بمساعدتنا
للفرق هذا وان نسهل كل الطرق
التي تساعد فرق الانقاذ متعازينا مره اخرى
ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل للجرحى
نعمل الا نعيش هذه الكوارث مره اخرى شكرا
جزيلا
ام علي الوزير هل لديكم اي معلومات عن
المدن الاخرى كيف هو الحال فيها حاليا كما
تعلمون
هناك تنسيق شامل مع الوزراء الاخرين وايضا
مع
السيدفؤاد الذي هو الان يدير شؤون التنسيق
لفرق الانقاذ وايضا التنسيق حول
مناطق الانقاد في المدن العشره
فاعملنا مستمره اعمال البحث مستمره
والانقاذ المستمره انا مسؤول عن مدينه
تيربكر حاليا الوزراء الاخرين المعنيين
يتابعون كل التطورات من المدن الاخرى التي
يتواجدنا فيها شكرا
اذا تبعنا وياكم هذه التصريحات لوزير
العدل التركي بكير تحدث فيها عن تنسيق
كامل وشامل بين المؤسسات الرسميه وغير
الرسميه
للمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ وقال نحاول ان
نسهل اعمل كل فرق الانقاذ في كافه
الولايات والمناطق التي تضررت جراء هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا صباح اليوم اذن
وفي تداعيات الموقف وصف الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرون الصور المروعه التي تصل من
تركيا وسوريا بعد الزلزال بغير المسبوقه
معلنا ان فرنسا على استعداد لتقديم
مساعدات عاجله الى السكان
الاتحاد الاوروبي بدوره ارسل فرق انقاذ
الى تركيا مؤكدا استعداده لمساعدتها بعد
الزلزال المستشار الالماني
عبر عن قلقه ازاء اخبار الزلزال في سوريا
وتركيا مؤكدا انهم حتما سيرسلون مساعدات
وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه اعلنت استعدادها
لارسال طائرتين الى تركيا للمساعده في
عمليات الانقاذ ادت واشنطن قلقها ازاء
التقارير عن الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
وسوريا مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
اكد ابلاغ تركيا باستعداد واشنطن المساعده
في جهود الانقاذ بعد الزلزال فيما اعلن
البيت الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
وجه بتقييم خيارات المساعده للمناطق
المنكوبه بالزلزال الرئيس الاوكراني
اعلن استعداد بلاده لمساعده الشعب التركي
السويد وعلى لسان وزير خارجيتها توبياس
بلستروم اكد استعدادها لمساعده تركيا
وسوريا بعد زلزال المدمر اما الخارجيه
البريطانيه فقد اعلنت استعدادها لتقديم
المساعدات لتركيا بعد الزلزال وزيره
خارجيه المانيا ايضا ان لينا اكدت انها
تبحث مع الشركاء جمع المساعدات
وارسالها الى تركيا وسوريا
نعيد التذكير معكم مشاهدينا الكرام بشكل
سريع بهذه الاخبار العاجل اسفل الشاشه
نذكر ايضا باخر الاحصائيات لهذه
او لهذا الزلزال المدمر وضحايا هذا
الزلزال 812 قتيلا في سوريا و14 قتيلا في
تركيا حتى هذه اللحظه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن يقول بانه وجه بمراقبه الوضع في
تركيا عن كتب في اعقاب الزلزال وامر
بتقديم اي مساعده تحتاج اليها قبل قليل
ايضا وزير خارجيه بريطاني قال سنرسل دعما
فوريا الى تركيا
للمساعده ويشمل فريق متخصص او فريق من سته
وسبعين متخصصا في البحث والانقاذ الكويت
امرت بانشاء جسر جوي الى تركيا للمساعده
في مواجهه اثار هذا الزلزال امير الكويت
اذا وجه بانشاء بانشاء جسر جوي الى تركيا
وكما ذكرنا
الخارجيه البريطانيه قالت بانها سترسل
مساعدات عاجله الى تركيا في عقاب الزلزال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ذكر اليوم
بان 45 دوله اعلنت استعدادها لتقديم
المساعدات والمساعدات العاجله ذكر بان
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو يشاركون فعلا في
المساعدات وفي عمليات الانقاذ ايضا كذلك
للمناطق والولايات المتضرره جراء هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا صباح اليوم واجزاء
من سوريا بقوه 7.8 درجات على مقياس ريختر
تحول مباشره
الى ابراهيم الادلبي الصحفي من الحدود
السوريه التركيه ابراهيم مرحبا بك معي مره
اخرى يعني ردود فعل كبيره ربما تتابعها
منذ اليوم باستعداد
يعني مكثف من الدول من الوكالات من
المنظمات من الاتحادات ايضا كذلك لكن على
الارض كيف يبدو واقع
العمليات الانقاذ والفرق المساعده وفرق
ايضا
الاسعاف التي تتواجد في اماكن تضرر سكان
المناطق القريبه منك اهلا وسهلا بك من
جديد الفرق الدفاع المدني والمدنيون
المتطوعون معها يحاولون انتشار بعض
العالقين تحت الانقاص في كل من سرمدا
وجنديرس ولا كارب التي لم تنتهي عمليات
البحث فيها حتى هذه اللحظه منذ ساعات
الصباح فيما تستمر المناشدات في كل من
سلقين لتوجه الاليات من اجل انتشار بعض
العوائل من تحت الانقاض خصوصا نعتمد على
بلاغات المدنيين الذين المتواجدين في
المناطق التي تضررت من الزلزال في عمق
الاراضي السوريه ان كان من جبل الزاويه
وقصوى الى المنطقه الى ريف حلب الشرقي
وصويره الى ريف ادلب الغربي هذه المناطق
كلها اتضررت من الزلزال السرقه الاسعاف
تعتمد ايضا على الكوادر المدنيه والسيارات
المدنيين في نقل المصابين وذلك بسبب نقص
في سيارات الاسعاف من الوقت سابق جراء
المكان عمليات الاستهداف المباشر منكم
اثناء الحرب او حتى
تعطل هذه السيارات بوقت سابق ولم يتم
اصلاحها بسبب التوقف الدعم او بعض من
الامدادات اللوجستيه في السيارات المدنيه
التي تحاول جاهده ايضا المساهمه بعمليات
النقل وحتى ايضا بعض السيارات التي تحولت
الى ماوى حقيقه على الشوارع العامه في ظل
هذه الظروف الجويه القاسيه من اجل محاوله
تامين بعض الضفه للاطفال الذين خرجوا من
منازلهم الذين من التجمعات السكنيه في بعض
القرى والبلدات في الاعلام الحدود الشريط
على الحدود الشريط السوري التركي فيما
ايضا العديد من المدنيين من من حلفهم من
حظ وصلوا الى تجمع المخيمات تجمع مخيمات
اطمه والمخيمات المحيطه بها في محاوله
للجوء لدى اخرين ضمن هذه الخيام لا يعرفهم
ايضا في الوقت ذاتي هناك بعض من المدنيين
ممن توجه باتجاه المخيمات العشوائيه
المنتشره ما بين القرى والبلدات في محاوله
منهم للبحث عن مؤولات الحياه وقليل من
الدفا خاصه ان الزلزال الاول كان قد بدا
منذ ساعات الصباح المبكر وهذه هي المره
الاولى التي يستهدف هكذا زلزال المنطقه
منذ زمن بعيد لذلك هناك نقص في الخبره
بالتعامل مع هكذا وضع
يعتمد المدنيون على
النداءات والتوجيهات التي
تطلقها كل من الدفاع المدني والمنظمات
المحليه طيب اضافه الى السلطات الحكوميه
الموجوده او اتحدث الحكومه المؤقته
والسلطات الموجوده التي تحاول ارشاد
المدنيين للابتعاد عن التجمعات السكنيه
المهترئه التي لم تخضع الى الصيانه منذ
وقت طويل يعني
السيد ابراهيم هذه المباني كما ذكرت
المهترئه هي مباني اصلا عانت من الحرب في
سوريا منذ عشره اعوام فهي بالاساس مباني
مهترئه يعني لم تكن تنتظر اسوا من حدوث
هذا الزلزال حتى تدمر بشكل كامل نعم صحيح
كما تحدثت المباني اجلها محترئ جراء
عمليات القصف السابقه او عدم الصيانه بسبب
عدم وجود السيوله الماليه والامر الخطير
بهذا الموضوع هي الملاجئ التي كانت تستخدم
بوقت سابق كمناطق احتمال المدنيين من
الغارات الجويه او حتى من القصف العشوائي
هذه الملاجئ اليوم ايضا كانت بامس الحاجه
لعمليه اعاده ترميم او وضع مؤولات الحياه
فيها خاصه ان المنطقه
[موسيقى]
مره اخرى يعني نسال عن هذه التحديثات
الاحصاءات ايضا وهذه المعلومات التي
تنقلها لنا من الحدود السوريه التركيه
ابقى معي ساعود اليك ينضم الينا الان من
القاهره الدكتور عباس شراقي استاذ
الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره دكتور عباس
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه المباشره من
العربيه اولا كيف تصف ما حدث هذا اليوم هل
هو حدث طبيعي ام حدث يعني غير طبيعي وحدث
يمكن ان نسال حوله وعنه الكثير
اولا تحياتي لحضرتك والساده المشاهدين
الحقيقه
ما حدث اليوم كارثه بمعنى الكلمه لم تحدث
من قبل لم نسجل مثل هذه الزلازل الحدث حتى
الان ما يقرب من زلزال في تركيا وحصل فيهم
فيهم يعني ثلاث زلازل كبرى يعني مش بس
زلزال اللي حصل في فجر اليوم اللي هو
بيشده سبعه وثمانيه من عشره بعديه حصل
زلزال سته وسبعه من عشره ومن ساعتين حصل
زلزال سته ونصف ومن ساعه واحده فقط حصل
زلزال شدته سته وواحد من عشره هذه السلسله
من الزلازل وحصلت ليس في مكان واحد في
اولا الشريط اللي فيه عدد الاكبر من
الزلازل واللي فيه الزلازل القويه بما
فيها الزلزال الكبير دي اللي هي المنطقه
الحدوديه ما بين تركيا وسوريا هذه اللي هي
التانيه دكتور هي هي
ليست زلازل
وتلتها يعني هزات ارتداديه
لا هو هو الزلزال الرئيسي حصل وتلاهي
زلزال بعده مباشره في نفس المكان بشده سته
وسبعه من عشره وبعدها مجموع الزلازل صغيره
لكن في مجموعه اخرى من الزلازل في اماكن
مختلفه لدرجه ان في زلزال في وسط تركيا
سبعه ونص وزلزاء ومجموعه زلازل اخرى في
غرب تركيا بعيد تماما عن المكان الاصلي
للزلزال الكبير ما هو التفسير العلمي يا
دكتور لهذه الحاله يعني هي حاله يا دكتور
بصراحه حولها الكثير من الاسئله
والاستفهامات وهي
الامور لم تكن متوقعه على الاقل الحاله
واضحه تماما
لا الحاله واضحه تماما بالنسبه لنا
جيولوجيين لان احنا عندنا
الافريقيه بتوجد في القشره الارضيه
فيما نسميه صفيحه او شريحه ارضيه هذه
الشريحه الافريقيه بتتواجد مع الشريحه
الاوروبيه والاسيويه مع بعض بيلتقوا عند
جزيره
قبرص
وتركيا موجوده في كتله صخريه ايضا هي
نفسها عامله شريحه صغيره وبتوجد مع
الاتنين فاذا التركيه عباره عن مجمع
لالتقاء هذه الشرائح التقاء الشرائح
معناها فوائد ضخمه جدا فتركيا من اشد
المناطق في العالم بعد المناطق المحيط
الهادي في الزلازل
اللي حصل ان احنا شفنا بنشوف زلازل يوميا
في تركيا وفي شرق البحر المتوسط في قبرص
لكن بتكون بش ونص فما بنعلقش عليها يعني
هي بتسجل يوميا لكن ما حدث في يمكن في
نوفمبر الماضي حصل مجموعه من الزلازل
وبعديها الزلزال اخر سته وواحد من عشره
وده كان يعتبر انذار لان احنا شفنا في
تركيا سنه 99 زلزال كان سبعه وسته من عشره
دكتور عباس يعني الدكتور عباس كان دكتور
عباس يعني كان اليوم من اللافت تغريده
اعيد الحديث عنها او التعليق ايضا حتى
عليها لاحد العلماء الهولنديين والذي كان
يتوقع حدوث الزلزال في هذه المنطقه بذات
الجغرافيه وبذات الدول ايضا وتحدث عن ان
زلزال قريب سيحدث في هذه المنطقه يعني كان
متاكد تماما اريد ان اسال هنا هل هناك
مراكز رصد او مراكز ابحاث او دراسات
تستطيع التنبؤ بهذه الحوادث او الزلازل
قبل وقوعها بفتره قصيره او فتره طويله
لا يوجد وسيله علميه في اي مكان في العالم
للتنبؤ بالزلازل وتحديد موعد حدوثها ولكن
هناك شواهد بنقول احنا لما حصل يعني في
الايام السابقه او في نوفمبر بالتحديد انا
يعني كنا راصدين بمجموعه من الزلازل
ومتتاليه على غير العالم
وفيها زلزال كان اشد سته واحد من عشره
فقلنا لا المنطقه دي فيها خطوره في نشاط
واضح اكتر من الزلازل اللي بتحصل لو عندنا
زلزال او اتنين بيحصل يوميا لا كان فيه
مجموعه من الزلازل فتعددت الزلازل حتى ولو
شدتها اقل لكن كثره الزلازل وبالتالي بقى
في انطباع ان انه احتمال يحصل بس امتى
يحصل الزلزال صعب ان احنا نحدده طب ما
احنا النهارده حتى صباحا وكل الانتباه في
المنطقه لكن مش قادرين نقول ان في زلزال
هيحصل مثلا الساعه ثلاثه او اذا هيحصل
الساعه خمسه يعني لكن احنا بنتوقع طالما
حصل ضخم اذا في توابع للزلزال هذا الزلزال
ممكن بينشط فوالا اخرى في المنطقه وليس في
نفس المنطقه اللي حصل فيها الزلزال في
توابح صحيح في نفس المركز ولكن هناك مناطق
اخرى بيحصل تنشيط في هذه الفوالق وبالتالي
احنا شفنا مجموعه زلازل ضخمه بعيده عن
الزلزال الاصلي اللي حصل اليوم وفي حديث
ايضا حتى يا دكتور كنت تابع على موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي يعني منذ اليوم الحديث
عن فائق البحر الميت الحديث عن زلزال يعني
قادم سيكون اكبر من هذا الزلزال وبان ما
حدث اليوم هو مقدمه لزلزال ربما يكون اكبر
باتساع وبجغرافيه اكبر من جغرافيه المنطقه
التي ضربها اليوم علميا يا دكتور هل هذا
الحديث مدعم
لم يحدث زلزال في هذه المنطقه اشد مما حدث
اليوم فاليوم غير مسبوق يمكن اللي شبيه به
زلزال سنه 39 كان شدته سبعه وتمانيه من
عشره وراح ضحيته حوالي 33 الف قتيل سنه 39
لكن اليوم يتفوق على زلزال 39 ان حصل معه
تلات زلازل اخرى كبرى اكتر من سته ونص
وهنا كل زلزال لوحده لو حصل لوحده ده يكفي
ان يعمل دمار في هذه المناطق فما بالنا ان
اربع زلازل وحولهم حوالي 100 زلزال اخر
بشده تتراوح حوالين خمسه ريختر اذا هذه
المجموعه من الزلازل لم تسجل من قبل في
التاريخ طيب
زلزال
اما بالنسبه للبحر الميت لا البحر الميت
هو ده امتداد الاخدود الافريقي اللي جاي
من البحر الاحمر احنا عندنا
جبال تركيا ونزل للجنوب البحر الميت ثم
خليج العقبه ثم البحر الاحمر ثم ندخل بقى
في اثيوبيا والخدود الافريقي هذه ده فعل
اكبر فعل على سطح الارض لكن الزلازل فيه
ليست بقوه الزلازل اللي بتحصل في تركيا
طيب الدكتور ايضا كان هناك حديث عن ان مثل
هذه الزلازل بشكل هذا الزلزال بشكل هذه
الارتدادات
وهو نفس طبعا العالم الجيولوجي الهولندي
في رده على احد المتابعين ذكر بان هناك ما
سيتبع هذه الزلازل وهذه الهزات وبانها
بانه سيكون هناك يعني موجه كبيره من
تسونامي ستضرب المناطق الساحليه التي
تضررت بهذا الزلزال هل هذا مرجح يا دكتور
خلال الايام القادمه
هذا هذا احتمال كبير
ان احنا دلوقتي احنا عندنا
الزلزال الكبير الرئيسي اللي هو سبعه
وتمانيه من عشره ده حصل في جنوب شرق تركيا
فعلى الحدود مع سوريا في الداخل ولكن احنا
شفنا زلازل اخرى حصلت في المنطقه الغربيه
في تركيا على السواحل في البحر المتوسط لو
حصل يعني هذه الزلازل بالقرب من على شواطئ
البحر المتوسط سوف تسبب تسونامي وسونامي
هنا معناه ان ارتفاع امواج البحر المتوسط
وتصل الى السواحل الافريقيه
بالتالي احنا بنرصد هذه الموجات وبنعرف
سرعتها وبيتم رصد وتبليغ كل المدن
الساحليه بان فيه موجه في موجه مرتفعه سوف
تصل الى السواحل بعد مده زمنيه محدده طبقا
لشده الزلزال وارتفاع الامواج وسرعتها ده
كله بيرصد حاليا وده
المنطقه بالكامل دلوقتي في حاله نشاط غير
مسبوق زلزالي سواء في شرق تركيا او في غرب
تركيا شرق البحر المتوسط بالكامل حاليا
متاهب لحدوث زلازل شفنا قبرص حصل فيها
مجموعه من الزلازل اليوم بعد زلزال تركيا
حصل في قبرص بس كان بيشد حوالي خمسه الى
خمسه ونصف هذه ايضا تعتبر شده يعني اعلى
من المتوسط طيب دكتور اخيرا هل هناك هزات
ارتداديه قريبه متوقعه بشكل كبير
مثل ما حدث اليوم تحدثنا عن اكثر
متوقع ان ممكن يحصل لان من ساعه واحده بس
فقط حصل زلزال شدته سته ونص هذه شده كبيره
6.5 ده من ساعه واحده ان يحصل خلال
الساعات القادمه ده متوقع انه يحصل لان
المنطقه بالكامل حاليا يعني نشطه من ناحيه
الزلزاليه هذه الزلازل بتشجع
انزلاقات في الفوالق في المجاوره في كل
المناطق في خصوص يعني بالتحديد في حوالين
المنطقه التركيه
في حلب
السوريه ايضا هذه اخر المنطقه دلوقتي طيب
الفوالق بتنشط بعضها طيب انا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على المشاركه معي في هذه التغطيه
المباشره من القاهره الدكتور عباس شراقي
استاذ الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره شكرا
جزيلا لك نعود مره اخرى لنذكر بهذا
الاخبار العاجله النظام السوري يعلق
الدراسه لمده اسبوع جراء الزلازل اعلام
النظام السوري تحدث عن هزتين متتاليتين في
حلب الكريم وقبل ذلك اعلن بان رجال انقاذ
من روسيا سيتوجهون الى سوريا
خلال الساعات المقبله
للمساعده اثراء الزلازل التي
ضربت طبعا تركيا واجزاء من سوريا صباح هذا
اليوم اذا وقعت انفجارات وحريق في قسمين
من خط انابيب للغاز في مدينه هاتاي
التركيه جراء الزلازل المدمره التي ضربت
جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا ذكرت وكاله
اخلاص التركيه للانباء ان السلطات التركيه
قررت تعليق توريد الغاز الى عدد من
المناطق الواقعه بالقرب من بؤر الهزات
الارضيه
من تحت الانقاض سماع نداء استغاثه في
مدينه جنديرس بعفرين في محافظه حلب التي
تضررت باضرار كبيره جراء الزلازل
وفي حلب ايضا اظهرت الصور في شارع بلال
بحي صلاح الدين انهيار مبنى بالكامل نشاهد
اعد مره اخرى الى ابراهيم الادلبي الصحفي
من الحدود السوريه التركيه سيدي ابراهيم
مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى قبل قليل ربما
تابعت معنا هذه الاخبار التي نقلها اعلام
النظام السوري بالاعلام طبعا عن هزتين
متتاليتين ارضيتين طبعا في حلب هل من اي
معلومات او تفاصيل جديده حول الهزات
الارضيه في سوريا نعم في استمرار للهزات
الارضيه منذ 20 دقيقه في الساعه الرابعه
وثمان دقائق كان هناك هزه ارتداديه شعر
بها المدني في كل من جرابلس والمناطق
الشماليه المتاخمه للحدود السوريه التركيه
لكن كانت بسيطه جدا والحمد لله فيما بالع
سؤالك ومدينه حلب ايضا حلب تعتبر من المدن
التي تضررت كثيرا جراء هذا الزلزال هناك
بعض الاوراق التي تؤكد وجود 27 حي من
احياء مدينه حلب كانوا قد تضرروا جراء
الزلزال الذي ضربهم صباحا او فجر هذا
اليوم في الساعه الرابعه وقليل ايضا هناك
اعداد القتلى في مدينه حلب كان لها النصيب
الاكبر بالنسبه للمحافظات السوريه اتحدث
عن المناطق القاضيه على سيطره النظام كل
من حماه وحلب واللاذقيه كان هناك انهيار
لاتحدث عن حيه سكن هنانو او شارع حنان كان
هناك انهيار لمبنى سكني كامل وايضا كان
هناك لا نحاول تسجيل بعض الاضرار داخل
الاحياء وخصوصا شحا المصادر لان المنطقه
تسيطر عليها قوات النظام فيما هناك عمليات
بحث وانقاذ بالنسبه للماجيل العالقين تحت
الركام داخل المدينه من قبل الجهات
المختصه هناك ما يحدث بالمثل بالنسبه لهذه
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا والتي
ايضا كان ونصيب من التضرر بسبب قربها من
مركز الزلزال الاول والزلزال الثاني كان
قد ضرب جنوب غرب تركيا وهي منطقه كان
مركزه كهرمان مرعش لذلك ايضا الهزا
الثانيه التي حدثت منذ قرابه الساعتين
تماما
ساعتين تماما ايضا ادت الى انهيار بعض
المباني في سرمدا وايضا في جرابلس لا تزال
المصادر شائعه في المنطقه الغربيه من
محافظه ادلب اتحدث عن جسر الشغور وريفيا
ايضا هي منطقه حقيقه المباني فيها هي
مباني قديمه لم تتعرض لاي عمليه صيانه
وخاصه ان هناك يوجد فيها تصدعات بسبب
الحرب وبسبب القصف الذي كانت تعرضت له
المنطقه هناك وعي كبير من المدنيين خرج
جلهم باتجاه الاراضي الزراعيه محاوله
للبقاء على قيد الحياه بعيدا عن المنشات
السكنيه التي قد
تتعرض لعمليه زلزال جديد قد يكون اقوى من
الاول او ان شاء الله لا تتعرض ولكن قد
يسبب على راس قاطنيها كما حدث الامر
وشاهدنا في سرمدا وفي الاتارب التي نالت
النصيب الاكبر من اعداد المدنيين هناك
سبعين مدني موثق حتى هذه اللحظه في مدينه
الاقارب كانوا قد لقوا حتفهم جراء انهيار
المباني بسبب الزلزال استهدفهم في ساعات
الصباح تحدثت معنا عن المباني عن قاطن هذه
المباني عن خروجهم ايضا الى الشوارع لكن
ماذا ايضا عن اللاجئين عن المخيمات ايضا
عن من يبطن هذه الخيام في ظل هذه الظروف
مدى التضرر الذي او الضرر الذي وقع عليهم
بسبب هذه الزلازل سيد ابراهيم الرصدت شيئا
نعم يؤسفني ان ابدا بالمقارنه ان من سقط
على راسه خيمه ليس كمن سقط على راسه مبنى
سكني ففي الحالتين الجميع متضرر من عمليه
الزلزال الاول والثاني وهناك بعض الخيام
التي خرجت عن الخدمه ولكن بنفس الوقت هناك
خيام كانت ما تزال مواقفه فتحت ابوابها
ايضا للمدنيين الذين نزحوا من
السكانيه باتجاه المناطق او المناطق
الخيام مع الاخذ بعي الاعتبار ان الطرق
المؤديه الى هذه الخيام اصبحت طرق طينيه
وحله بسبب العاصفه ان كانت الثلجيه التي
ضربت منذ صباح الامس او حتى العاصفه
المطريه المستمره حتى هذه اللحظه للمنطقه
هناك صعوبه للوصول الى المخيمات اضافه الى
ان المنطقه اصبحت منطقه وحليه الجميع ان
المخيمات مبنيه او موجوده في مناطق
المناطق كانت تستخدم مناطق زراعيه سابقا
او ما بين الاشجار اي انها ليست ارضيه
صلبه فهي ارضيه طينيه الوضع يزداد سوء
بالمخيمات ولكن للاسف عند عندما نبدا
المقارنه ما بين المتضررين والمتضرر اكثر
اي المخيمات والمباني السكنيه دائما
سنتحدث عن كميات او عن اعداد هائله كانوا
قد لقوا حذفهم في تحت المنازل حتى الان لا
توجد احصائيات رسميه او دقيقه بالنسبه لمن
لقى حتفهم في المجمعات السكنيه اما الخيام
فكان وضعهم افضل افضل سواء من بقيه
المناطق خاصه انهم
يحاولون مساعده جميع من اجل الاهتمام من
العاصفه المطريه وتقديم ما يملكون او
يشاركون المدنيين ما يملكون من قوتهم داخل
خيامهم التي قد كانوا قد مكنسوا فيها منذ
قرابه الثماني او تسع سنوات عندما تم
افتتاح هذه المخيمات على شريط الحدود
السوري التركي طبعا الان الرئيس المصري
كما نشاهد في شريط العاجل اسفل الشاشه
يعلن استعداد بلاده لارسال المساعدات
لسوريا وتركيا لمواجهه اثار الزلازل لهذه
الصور نتابعها الان على شاشه العربيه من
ادايا من في تركيا ولايه اديمان في تركيا
لنقل المصابين المتضررين من الزلزال ومن
طبعا انهيار بعض المباني بشكل كلي او بشكل
جزئي بعضهم ضحايا بعضهم طبعا جرحه والبعض
الاخر ايضا لا يستطيع يعني ان يمشي على
قدميه الى داخل المستشفى صور اخرى ايضا
هذا الزلزال المدمر او هذه الزلازل
المدمره التي ضربت اليوم تركيا وسوريا على
درجه 7.8 ريختر عمليه الانقاذ لا زالت
متواصله صور من ادلب كنا قد شهدنا واياكم
قبل قليل على شاشه العربيه محاولات انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه من تحت الانقاذ ومن تحت
هذه المباني التي هدمت فوق
رؤوس قاطنيها وسكنها وكما ذكر قبل قليل
ابراهيم الادلبي الصحفي من الحدود السوريه
التركيه فيبدو ان الاوضاع في المخيمات
مخيمات اللاجئين هي افضل سوءا من غيرهم
بعد هذه طبعا جمله هذه
الزلازل وكذلك العاصفه المطريه القويه
التي تضرب هذه المناطق ايضا بعد الزلزال
الذي راح ضحيته 812 شخصا في سوريا و14 في
تركيا حتى هذه اللحظه تركي ذكر هذا اليوم
في مؤتمره الصحفي بان الاصابات فاقت خمسه
الاف اصابه حتى هذه اللحظه وبان هناك
اعداد كبيره ايضا من
المفقودين اردوغان ايضا اشار بان 45 دوله
عرضت المساعده بعد الدمار الكبير في نحو
11 ولايه اذا هذه صور اخرى ننقلها لكم
طبعا لمحاولات الانقاذ والاسعاف لبعض من
تضرروا جراء هذا الزلزال وطبعا لا زالوا
عالقين تحت
الانقاض وتحت المباني المهدمه
اذا من تحت الانقاض سماع نداء استغاثه في
مدينه جنديرس بعفرين في محافظه حلب التي
تضررت باضرار كبيره جر الزلزال متابع
يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
اذا الان اداره الكوارث التركيه مشاهدينا
تعلن ارتفاع عدد
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا ضحايا الزلزال الى مئه
وواحد وعشرين قتيلا اذا في اخر الاحصائيات
قتيلا حتى هذه اللحظه هذه اخر طبعا
الاحصاءات التي طلعتنا بها اداره الكوارث
التركيه اذا ارتفاع ضحايا الزلزال في
تركيا الى 1121 قتيلا اخر الانبا كانت
تتحدث عن 14
قتيلا وطبعا اكثر من 5000 مصاب جراء هذه
الزلازل والتي اعلن عنها طبعا الرئيس
التركي رجب طيبه اردوغان في حديثه الصحه
في ظهيره هذا اليوم لا تزال الارقام في
سوريا حتى هذه اللحظه 812 قتيلا
وارتفع طبعا في تركيا الى
1221 قتيلا كما يظهر في اسفل الشاشه
في شريط الاخبار العاجله في حلب ايضا
مشاهدينا سوريا اظهرت الصور في شارع بلال
بحي صلاح الدين انهيار مبنى بالكامل نشاهد
مباشره الى مراسل العربيه من القامشلي
جمعه عكاش جمعه مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه الارقام في سوريا حتى هذه اللحظه
تشير الى 822 قتيلا حدثت هذه الارقام قبل
قليل في تركيا لكن بالنسبه لسوريا هل من
جديد في ارقام الضحايا والاصابات حتى الان
نعم مرحبا بك ويسعد المشاهدين الاعداد
تحدث بالمئات في هذه الكارثه يعني قبل
ساعتين كان العدد 221 في مناطق المعارضه
337 في مناطق نظام ارتفع في مناطق
المعارضه الى 400 400 قتيل في مناطق نظام
480 وفقا للمصادر الرسميه طبعا يعني العدد
الان
804 اشخاص فقدوا حياتهم هناك احصائيه تقول
ان العدد هو 812 شخصا فقدوا حياتهم لكن
حسب متابعتنا لعمليات انتشال الجثث
وانقاذ يعني انقاذ الوصول الى اماكن ابعد
في ازاله الركام وحطام المنازل هذا العدد
مرشح لان يبلغ حوالي الف قتيل وفقا لاعمال
يعني ازاله الانقاذ والركام
المنازل بينما اعداد الاصابات
بالالاف لا يمكن وضع يعني رقم دقيق لاع
الاصابات يعني الاصابات المتفاوته من
خفيفه متوسطه الى بالغه الخطوره معظم يعني
المصابين الذين ذهبوا الى المشافي
الميدانيه سواء في عفرين او في
جمعه طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال
بالزميل جمعه عكاش من القمش لمراسل
العربيه سنعود الى جمعه مره اخرى حاله جهز
هذا الاتصال وتخطينا هذا الخلل الفني من
مصدره مباشره الى زيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه من اسطنبول زيدان مرحبا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه زيدان اداره الكوارث التركيه
قبل قليل والازمات تحدثت عن ارتفاع اعداد
الاصابات في تركيا الى 1121
قتيلا الاصابات حتى هذه اللحظه ربما فقط
5000 اصابه وتزيد ايضا بكثير معلومات
المتوفره لديك حول هذا الشان
نعم قبل ثواني فقط اعلن رئيسه الطوارئ
التركيه في كلمه القاها في العاصمه
التركيه انقره عن الحصيله الجديده لعدد
الضحايا الزلزال حتى الان
1121 شخصا هم عدد الضحايا في نتيجه هذا
الزلزال هؤلاء لقوا مصاعهم نتيجه الزلزال
والهزاف الارتداديه التي شهدتها الولايات
الجنوبيه في تركيا عدد الاصابات بحسب هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه افادت
اصابه اكثر من 2000 او تحديدا
2,834 مبنى دمر بحسب ما رصدته هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه نتحدث عن زياده
في عدد الضحايا
عن الاحصائيه السابقه التي كانت 1014 شخصا
اي ان لدينا 110 اشخاص جدد قد لقوا مسرعهم
نتيجه الزلزال بالنسبه لعدد
المنازل المدمره هو نفس الاحصائيه السابقه
وايضا بالنسبه لعدد الجرحى هو نفس
الاحصائيه
طيب ساعود اليك زيدان ابقى معي لكن اتحول
مباشره الى عمان ومعي من هناك رولا الامين
المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا سيترول مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه يعني تتابعينا منذ الصباح هذه
الاحداث
مراسل العربيه كان قد نقل في وقت سابق بان
هناك عشرات الالاف من
المشردين ايضا ممن خرجوا من منازلهم
بتحسبا طبعا لاي هزات ارتداديه جديده او
اي زلازل جديده انتم في المفوضيه الساميه
للامم المتحده كيف تعلقون حدث ما الذي
ستقدمونه يعني لمن تضرر جراء هذه الزلازل
طبعا المفوضيه
موجود في سوريا سواء في المناطق التي تخضع
لفتره النظام او في المناطق نحن نحاول
الوصول عائلاتهم والذين تشردوا يعني
الخسائر ليست فقط بالارواح للاسف هناك
خسائر بالارواح وهذا الموضوع مروع وصديقي
وهناك من خسرت بيوت بيته وتشتت العائله
وهناك ارتدادات لهذه الهذا الزلزال يعني
تنشئ خوف عند الناس من
العوده وهناك
تشردوا لانهم اصلا في معظمهم نازحون يجب
ان نتذكر انه يوجد اكثر من 6.8 مليون سوري
ما زالوا داخل سوريا
انهم يعيشون اما في خيم او في المباني
ربما
مهدمه او مباني قد تضررت وهذا يعني انها
مبال ضعيفه وبالتالي
فقد هناك يعني لا يشعرون انهم محميون داخل
هذه البيوت هم يذهبون الى خارج هذه البيوت
وهناك عاصفه ثلجيه قويه جدا تضرب المنطقه
الى الثلوج الى الامطار الغزيره رياح
شديده جدا ولا يوجد لديهم اي خيار اخر هذا
وضع معتز يجب ان نتذكر ان هذا الزلزال
يضرب سوريا وتركيا في وقت هناك يعني ازمات
متعدده يمر فيها السوريون
الارض هناك الازمه السوريه هناك الازمه
الاقتصاديه هناك تداعيات اثار جائحه وهناك
التضخم الاقتصادي
العالم بينهم وهذا يعني ان هؤلاء كانوا
يطارعون بالبقاء على قيد الحياه لحمايه
اسرهم والان ضرر هذا الزلزال
فيها وضرب
احد طيب انتم ذكرتي قبل قليل بانكم
حاولتوا التواصل مع يعني بعض الاسر وبعض
الضحايا بعض ايضا من شردوا او فقدوا يعني
وتفرقوا بعد هذه الزلازل يعني ما الذي
وصلتم اليه وكذلك ما هي نوعيه المساعدات
التي
تقدمونها لهؤلاء الاسر ايضا لمن اصيبوا
كذلك من يقتلون ايضا هذه البيوت المهدمه
اصلا قبل ان تنهدم على رؤوسه
صحيح صحيح نحن لدينا في المنطقتين شركاء
على الارض هؤلاء جمعيات ومؤسسات تتعاون
معنا نحن نوفر البطانيات المراتب الفرشاه
لوازم التد
فئه توزيعها وايطالها الى كل من يحتاج الى
هذه المساعده
ولكن يعني هناك تحديات فمثلا في منطقه
ادلب هذه العواصف الثلجيه والامطار
بعدها من غازي عنتاب من سوريا ايضا
في قلب هذا الزلزال
وهناك صعوبه في الطرقات التي جرفتها
المياه لذلك هناك صعوبه ايضا في ايصال
المساعدات ولكن نحن نبذل كل الجهد لايصال
هذه المساعدات باسرع وقت ممكن وداخل سوريا
ايضا نحن نعمل مع بقيه الوكالات الامم
المتحده الاخرى لتوفير المساعدات للعائلات
التي تشردت للجرحى ربما لاعطائهم خيم
احيانا معاصف ادوات للطهي لانهم تشردوا من
بيوتهم بعض منهم ربما للمره العاشره
الكثير منهم يضطر للنزوح من بيته بحثا عن
الامن والامان عده مرات والان يهربون من
الملاجئ الهشه التي وجدوا فيها
خوفا من الزلزال وتتبع
اليوم لهذه الاحداث سيده رولا يعني
يعرف بان اكثر ما يحتاج اليه هؤلاء
المتضررين من هذا الزلزال هو المساعدات
الطبيه محاوله يعني انقاذ
من اصيبوا الجرحى ايضا باختلاف اصاباتهم
ربما متوسطه او حرجه او غيره في هذا
الاطار ما الذي ستقدمه لهم الامم المتحده
كيف ستساعد الطاقه الاستيعابيه لهذه
المستشفيات او المراكز الطبيه الموجوده في
الحدود السوريه التركيه او داخل ايضا
سوريا او حتى ايضا في بعض المناطق التركيه
غازي عنتاب على سبيل المثال ليست قادره
على على هذا الكم الهائل على استقبال هذا
الكم الهائل سواء من الضحايا او حتى من
المصابين
لذلك الجهود يعني تمتد على كل هذه الاطعمه
انا تحدثت عن البطانيات والفرشات والمراتب
والخيم لان المفوضيه تعني بهذه الامور
ولكن لدينا زملاء الامام المتحده ايضا
منظمه الصحه العالميه الذين لديهم ايضا
الطواقي الطبيه ولديهم الامدادات الطبيه
التي
يصمم ونحن نتعاون معهم على كل هذه الامور
الاحتياجات كبيره
الاحتياجات امنيه وهناك احتياجات
يعني ستستمر لاشهر من الان افطار هذا
الزلزال تتكشف مع ستتكشف مع كل يوم وستكون
لها اثار مدمره هناك خوف هناك قلق هناك
خساره ماديه وخ بالارواح وهناك خساره بيوت
وماوى
المهم جدا ان هؤلاء يعني
اما يحتاج تحتاج هذه العائله وان تنتهي
هذه الازمه
وان يعم السلام في سوريا والمنطقه يتمكنوا
من العوده وان يتمكنوا من استئناف حياتهم
وان
لا يتحملوا الزلازل والعواطف والشتاء وهم
يعيشون في الخيم وفي اماكن هشيشه جدا الان
المرصد السوري ينقل بان النظام المعارضه
غير قادرين على انقاذ ضحايا الزلزال بسبب
العدد الكبير اريد ان اسال سيد رولا كذلك
عن ما هي المناطق التي لم تستطيع الوصول
اليها سواء كان بسبب احوال الطقس القاسيه
ونحن في الشتاء وكذلك يعني ربما بصعوبه
وعوره الطرق التي تؤدي اليها بسبب هذا
الزلزال الذي خلف الكثير من الدمار ربما
في الطرق المؤدي الى هذه المناطق
صحيح يعني
نحن هنا ليس هذه هذه ليست اول مره سنقدم
فيها المساعدات نحن موجودون في سوريا في
جميع المناطق منذ اعوام ومنذ حتى قبل
الازمه ولدينا شركاء على الارض
والزملاء الموجود
ويحاولون
الوصول يعني يجب ان نكون ايضا موضوعيين
ويجب ان نكون هناك عقبات قويه هناك عقبات
الرسول بسبب كل الظروف التي حضرتك ذكرتها
هناك احيانا تمويل ايضا يعني نحن حتى قبل
هذه
الفاجعه كانت لدينا صعوبه في ايصال
المساعدات الشتويه لان المساعدات برنامج
المساعدات الشتويه كان يجب ان يصل لاكثر
من
فاصله اربعه مليون ناجح ولاجئ في سوريا
والمنطقه ولكن للاسف لم نتمكن
هناك تمويل كافي وهذا ايضا جزء من
المشكلات يجب ان يكون هناك نهضه في تقديم
المساعدات في السوريين
والناجحين لان هذا وقت اصدار صعب جدا جدا
وعلى الجميع مساندتهم نحن دائما نقول
الاحتياجات الانسانيه يجب ان تكون بعيدا
عن السياسه هذه اللحظه بالذات هي اللحظه
التي يجب ان نضع السياسه جانبا ونك
فر بيوتنا
الانسان اشكرك يا جزيل الشكر من عمان رولا
الامين المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الساميه
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
اظهرت لقطات جويه مصوره تم التقاطها في
مدينه اضنه التركيه عشرات من عمال الانقاذ
وهم يبحثون عن ناجينا فوق حطام مبنى منهار
[موسيقى]
ونعود مره اخرى الى مراسل العربيه من
القمش لجماعه مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى هل
تسمعني الان اولا نعم مرحبا بك طيب جمعه
كنت اتحدث معك قبل قليل كنت اسال عن
الاوضاع الميدانيه هل تطورت هل تحدثت
الارقام ايضا كذلك قبل قليل كان يتحدث
المرصد السوري كان يتحدث طبعا عن صعوبه في
الانقاذ صعوبه في انقاذ المصابين او حتى
في يعني انقاذ الضحايا سواء من النظام او
من المعارضه يعني بانهم غير قادرين تماما
على انقاذهم بسبب العدد الكبير على الارض
هل هذا صحيح
نعم هذا صحيح صحيح بالتاكيد لان اعداد
الاصابات وهي بالالاف اضافه الى اعداد
يعني القتلى الذي هو في تزايد مستمر يفوق
امكانيات اطراف الصراع في في سوريا سواء
كان النظام او حتى
المعارضه ربما اوضاع النظام افضل بقليل من
اوضاع المعارضه التي يعني تعيش حاله حصار
من جهه الداخل السوري وايضا يعني
قله الموارد وايضا قله الامكانيات
والمعابر المغلقه تضع يعني المعارضه امام
كارثه انسانيه للتعامل مع هذا الملف
الانساني الذي يصبح اكثر تعقيدا بمرور
الدقائق وليس فقط يعني
[موسيقى]
الساعات يعني اعداد القتلى يرتفع بالمئات
وليس بالعشرات مثلا منذ حوالي ساعتين كان
اعداد القتلى في مناطق
الان اصبح 400 نحن نتحدث عن 179 قتيل
زياده على العدد الاساسي في غضون ساعتين
فقط نتحدث عن الاف الاصابات عشرات
العائلات عالقه تحت الانقاض لا تستطيع فرق
الدفاع المدني والفرق الشعبيه التي تشكلت
لدعم يعني فريق الدفاع المدني الانتشار
الجثث ورفع الانقراض والركام
المنازل بينما في مناطق في مناطق نظام
ايضا يعني كان العدد
337 اصبح 404 نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من تنميات
قتيل في حصيله في حصيله غير نهائيه في
عموم سوريا ونتحدث عن الاف
المصابين اصابات مختلفه من صغيره الى
متوسطه الى اصابات كبيره ودقيقه تتطلب
تدخل جراحي يعني لا الامكانيات الطبيه ولا
الكادر الطبيه ولا حتى الوقت يسعف يعني
القطاع الطبي للتعامل الاعداد الكبيره
المصابين الكثير منهم اصاباتهم عصبيه
نتيجه يعني كسور في العظام ويعني التضرر
في الجمجمه وتضرر في الدماغ وبالتالي يعني
تحتاج مناطق المعارضه وايضا حتى مناطق
النظام الى التدخل خارجي اسعافي
يعني
لتحقيق امكانيه السيطره على هذه
المشكله او الكارثه الكبيره الحاصله في
سوريا طبعا الان مراسل العربيه ينقل بان
هناك هزه ارتداديه في بغداد شعر بها جزء
من سكان العاصمه العراقيه اذا مراسل
العربيه نتحدث عن هزه ارتداديه في بغداد
شعر بها جزء من سكان العاصمه العراقيه
وكنا قد تابعنا ظهرا اليوم نقله مراسل
العربيه في كردستان العراق تحديدا في دهوك
واربي ايضا هناك يعني مشاعر بهزات
ارتداديه في هذه المناطق نشاهد طبعا
واياكم على الشاشه مشاهدينا هذه
الصور اذا التي ننقلها لكم من المناطق
التي تضررت جراء هذا الزلزال محاولات
الانقاذ مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه وبعد ذلك
الصور الجويه
الزلزال الذي دمر شمال سوريا دمره العديد
من المباني في الشمال السوري صباحا اليوم
الارقام يعني من سوريا لا زالت ارقام غير
غير دقيقه تماما حتى هذه اللحظه نحن نصل
الى 812 قتيلا هناك الكثير من المفقودين
سواء المصابين او منهم تحت الانقاذ حتى
هذه اللحظه او من حتى شردوا من منازلهم
خوفا من عوده هذه الزلازل او الهزات
الارتداديه التي عقيدت الزلازل الرئيسيه
الزلزال طبعا مشاهدينا حتى اللحظه 812
قتيلا في سوريا و 1121 قتيلا في تركيا حتى
هذه اللحظه اذا وكان طبعا الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان قد تحدث
ظهر اليوم في مؤتمرا صحفي بان هذه الكارثه
وهذا الزلزال هو الكارثه الاكبر في
التاريخ التركي منذ عام
1939 وتحدث ايضا كذلك عن الاصابات التي
فاقت خمسه الاف اصابه حتى هذه اللحظه
عمليه انقاذ لا زالت مستمره كما نشاهد
يسار الشاشه اعود مره اخرى الى جماعه كاش
مراسل العربيه جمعه السؤال عن
المساعدات الطبيه ايضا كذلك عن فرق
الانقاذ وعن حتى ربما الفرقه التابعه
للامم المتحده هل وصلت الى مناطق القامشلي
وما حولها نوعيه المساعدات ان كان قدم شيء
حتى الان
بخصوص يعني المساعدات الدوليه هناك 45
دوله بما فيها دول الاتحاد الاوروبي عرضت
المساعده على سوريا لكن السؤال الاهم هو
هل تستطيع هذه الدول يعني تقديم الدعم
مباشره على الارض الاجابه لماذا لان
الكثير من هذه الدول لا تطبع مع النظام
السوري وترفض التعامل معه ايضا المساعدات
التي تاتي عن طريق عنق الامم المتحده كانت
السيده رولا الامين تتحدث
منذ قليل عن يعني عدم القدره للوصول الى
هذه المناطق وكانت تستخدم السياسه
فيكلماتي عندما استخدمت يعني الطقس وظروف
الزلزال لعدم الوصول نحن كصحفي نعرف بان
الامم المتحده تتعرض الى نوع من الابتزاز
والفساد عندما تمر من دمشق الى مناطق
الاكراد والى مناطق المعارضه لذلك يعني
هذه هذه العمليات اضاعه المساعدات التي
دمشق تثير قلق الامم المتحده وبالتالي
المساعدات لا تصل الى الاناس المعنيين وهو
ما يعرقل بشكل كبير عمليات الامم المتحده
في الداخل السوري سواء شمال غرب سوريا او
شمال شرق سوريا لذلك الدول المانحه
التحالف الدولي المنظمات الدوليه غير
الربحيه جميعها يعني تحاول الوصول اما عبر
تركيا او عبر او عبر يعني كردستان العراق
الى الى المناطق يعني الموبوءه وبالتالي
هذه ايضا هي مغلقه
بشكل كبير وصول المساعدات الى المنتظرين
بشكل مباشر جمعه سنتابع معك في سياق
الساعات المقبله في تغطيه العربيه
المباشره
والحيه لتطورات
واثار الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا واجزاء من
سوريا حتى هذه اللحظه امتداداته وصلت الى
العراق
كذلك ايضا الى لبنان وصلت ايضا كذلك الى
مناطق اخرى كانت تتحدث ويتحدث ايضا مسؤول
دنماركي عن وصولها الى منطقه جرينلاند
تغطيتنا من استوديوهات العربيه في الرياض